could a shift in the magnetic poles
happen in the near future how does that
occur and what would that mean for both
humans biologically as well as
technologically okay dude with the poles
are shifting all the time okay
oh all right and we say Oh compass
points north
no it points to the North Magnetic Pole
which is not near the north geographic
pole like we said Santa is like North
Pole Bar None all right the Magnetic
Pole is like in Canada somewhere all
right
so people who in the old days pre GPS
who hiked with compasses would need a
magnetic what they called it was it a
declination or decrement they need to
know what angle difference between the
compass and true north would give you
depending on where they were in the
world is that what true north comes from
June or PSA that is the Worf this Santa
right and true north is the difference
between north and magnetic north that
difference you have to keep track of
that otherwise you're lost all right so
a compass is only good as how close the
North Pole is to the North Pole
all right that's you know here's
something cool you ready do you realize
that the North Pole of a compass points
to the North Pole of the earth but
you've played with magnets before mm-hmm
what happens when you bring two North
Pole's together well they cut up hate
each other they repel right yet your
North Pole on a magnet is pointing to
the North Pole of the earth that tells
you that Earth's North Pole actually has
the South Magnetic Center oh it's dead
and so it's just the opposite just the
office it is just the opposite the North
Magnetic Pole the earth is earth South
Pole
that's why Walden north poles of magnets
point there oh my that is amazing you
didn't know that no no because you dick
it's North Pole
that's what you could get what's your
point - Matt you're north but you're
right but the North Pole of the magnet
would not point towards the North Pole
it would go be I was like the opposite
so the North Pole is actually the South
Pole
exactly hey I'm just saying so Santa's
truly at the South Pole yes uh near the
South Magnetic does sound like the real
rotation will resume exactly so the
poles not only wander they've actually
diminished in intensity and increased
over time right now we're on a
diminishing intensity Pole the worry is
if it goes away then what happens to
their like solar particles and radiation
that hits the earth do we all go extinct
yes we're worried about that so you look
at the record of where the pole has been
we have that because it freezes quote
freezes into the lava that comes out of
volcanoes it remembers what orientation
the pole was at the time it solidified
so you have a whole tracking of the
history of where the magnetic pole was
and after this break you'll find out
whether we go extinct or not your
service starts on media back in a moment
in a previous segment someone asked what
would happen to life if the Earth's
magnetic field that's right in fact that
dynamo everyone said I forgot to say we
have evidence that the magnetic field
has gone away many times before oh
because it goes to 0 as it flips our
main field fit everything field has
flipped several too many times in the
past its flipped so ok so it happened
and so when it flipped it goes to 0 you
can look at the fossil record while we
have 0 magnetic field they Charon are
making babies just fine so whatever is
their version of a baby is just fine so
it does not appear to be as severe as
you might think
ok the evidence show that's good to know